okay for people who are joining this
live stream
this is looking at language completeness
and consistency
heading into version 12.2 of language
all right first issue is the third
argument for
throw suggested
christopher suggests the third argument
with the value for when the uncaught
throw
so i can explain why so there's no so
that there's no enclosing catch
so if the throw returns to the top level
what should it do
right right and this is sort of an
important thing i think because
the basic thing is that right throw and
catch is pretty much
the general way of doing exceptions and
you could pretty much use throw and
catch to implement the other exception
handling mechanisms
pretty much except for the fact they all
have different behavior
when there's no catch effectively and so
this is sort of
you know if users are supposed to be
able to implement these sort of control
flow things
there needs to be some way of specifying
what happens when
basically it's malformed and there is no
catch
and so what's your proposal of what the
argument actually does
well so this is sort of the the
discussion so one option
is that it just be an expression that
that throw be made hold all
and that the third argument is just an
expression that gets evaluated and
returned at the top level
when when things go wrong so
realistically would be something like
message of blah blah blah and maybe like
a dollar failed or
probably not a dollar failed something
like that that's one option
um the other option that i think tom was
in favor of because um
this wouldn't require changing the
attributes would be to have a pure
function as the third argument
which would then probably take uh the
arguments to the throw
um i think that the more consistent
thing is probably to do
the first version of just having a an
expression that you evaluate because
that's what like lookup does or time
constrained or memory constrained etc
or check but i think that also
practically if basically
the purpose of this argument is to be
something that
throws a message when because it's you
know this argument
something has gone wrong when you reach
this argument um then it might be easier
to
write code that generates a message if
you're sort of given that pure
if you're giving those arguments i agree
i think it needs the arguments to
throw yes i i i
think that right so so tom's point
wasn't so much the whole doll versus
non hold all although that is a tiny bit
of something
that's my point actually because i don't
like hold all i think
it's much we have function that's that's
what we have
we should use function not making things
hold on
making things bit like functions right
okay well let's see
so i mean the only thing is i do think
it is kind of inconsistent for it to be
a function
but i think it is also like for the
actual use case it's probably going to
be
more common that you'll want to do it
like that right because of course you
don't gain any information
by having right so the arguments that
function will presumably just be the
first two arguments to throw
right but you don't you already have
those arguments when you're when you're
generating the third argument
right it's more abstracted it's more
abstracted though
because you can have a whole load of
throws and have one function that
handles all of them
whereas you know otherwise you'd have to
sort of think and concoct a different
expression to throw that you know
bundled up the arguments
so it's it's more abstractive to have a
function
well you could also just define a
function that calls throw right
and that will look at its argument and
then produce the correct third of course
you can
you you there are alternatives but yeah
i'm just saying it's more abstracted
without having to i think it's okay to
have the spear function i mean i
understand the precedent
and we certainly do have some functions
i mean not maybe not so much in this
class but we do have
functions where the right where the
default action is a pure function rather
than an expression
sure
it seems okay to me i mean i think it's
more useful to have it be a function
because i think it's going to be applied
to the value and so on
i mean i can't imagine why you wouldn't
want to apply it to the value even if
you're putting a failure object around
it
correct yeah i think that's the more
that's the convincing argument
okay do we need to add something to the
documentation for this
right now i mean is this implementable
guys
easily yeah it's easily implementable
it's more or less done yeah i mean the
version where just evaluates the
expression is done it's sitting in a
pull request but i mean
it's easy to modify it so it just takes
that function
okay
um well let's just i'm just waiting for
my documentation to update and then
we'll
go ahead and do this okay
well uh right so i mean i i
i looked at the futurized rough page for
with cleanup
um and it's sort of mixing a bunch of
different things which certainly don't
all behave
the same way and so uh we should
and i think there's some consensus that
they shouldn't all behave the same
problem with documentation what's this
what's this about uh
that looks like
uh well that looks like a bug in your
script or something
oh no there's a bunch of things called
new
oh yeah which were which were deleted
so
on which i'm about to bring back somehow
uh possibly
i mean we've certainly had this problem
in the past
okay sending mail about this that wasn't
the directory
issue was it because that that didn't
look normal
but that's what yeah
all right i'm sending now just saying it
looks like um i don't think it's going
to affect the things we're dealing with
right now
and i don't see that you have
immediately just now created them
so that's a good sign
all right
so with respect to throw
that's just a third case
here that says throw
value tag f
applies f
i think it evaluates f of value comma
tag
right okay
um gives well gives f
a value comma tag
um
what is it it's not the value as the as
the value
it's really weird it does
it's really totally weird i mean that
this is sort of the
the conceptual complaint about this is
that the concept of quotes returning at
the top level
is not necessarily well defined
especially like cloud evaluations and
things
and also it's just something totally
weird but at the same time
there are already functions like throw
or like you know return go to etc
which already have behavior where they
have to do something and so this is just
defining it
but it is totally weird what's that the
thing here an error is generated an
unevaluated throw is returned
oh i see that undervalued so that we
have to change now
or no the default is that that's correct
right right in the absence of the third
argument
um
if if there is no
appropriate
if no appropriate catch is found
because as the top level
returns
you could say returns blah to the top
level
well i think we're gonna have to explain
what a top level value is
that doesn't this is what i was saying
about it's totally weird
at some level this concept doesn't
really i mean
look it's when you call top eval but
that concept doesn't like that's not
something that
we usually make a distinction for and
there are going to be weird cases like
with cloud evaluating and so on where
it's not going to quite make sense
there's a catch-all function though
isn't there it's like check all or
whatever it's called
that's that's the thing not visible
it's not documented yeah might be
documented
in the internal context i'm not sure in
as an internal page but
um
okay
this is better than what libon wine does
anyway
um this needs to be i i i don't think i
should
finish off all of this um
no i think it's probably better to yeah
let's let's keep going with this meeting
but but then this needs to be
a little bit of work needs okay with
clean up back to work cleanup
so it's uh you've been you're objecting
to something here
yes that it's wrong
okay um and whether or not whether or
not it's desirable
um is what we need of a second question
we need the function but what's wrong
right so it's claiming that all of these
things are
disabled which first of all is not true
because
interrupt and interactive interrupts are
not in any way
affected by with cleanup or in
internal with local settings um and they
can't
really be um second of all
um it's not true that
uh throws and catch are
uh um
right so so look at the examples right
the throw and catch are different
from certainly the abort no no the the
examples in my notebook
um so
um
right so it's not true that throw is
delayed until the end
of with local settings um
it is sort of
delayed i guess
it's sort of half delayed it's still the
the actual throw doesn't
succeed until after the third argument
is
evaluated but it
does activate in
the first or third arguments and
terminate the rest of the
of that part of the evaluation
which is different from the normal
aborts
what does the normal report do it's
completely disabled until after
everything has finished evaluated in
with local settings
i mean look at the example do you
understand what's happening here
christopher
i am not really the with local settings
expert but i mean i think that
so this is the first thing is is about
interrupt i mean i just tried in it
looks like interrupt
does actually pretty much behave like a
board does
um local settings at least once you
press the button in the dialog
well if you press the button to abort it
behaves the same
but interrupt but enter but the
interrupt dialog will appear right away
and sit for you waiting for you to
respond no matter
whether you're going inside of with
inside you're inside of with local
settings or not
sure um but right but then i think that
maybe the more concerning one is this
throw one
which is which i think there was a long
email discussion about this
which i think that i i don't know about
you itai but it seems like
maybe it's people generally think that
this is probably the right behavior
but it is very weird which is that
basically the throw
will okay the throw will basically
if you have a throw in the first or the
third argument it will
stop evaluation of that argument
then it will go to the cleanup it'll run
the third argument
and then it will the throw will get sort
of propagated
right so this is as opposed to abort for
example where
if you write abort it just pretty much
gets uh
it just pretty much gets ignored the
point is that a board is not a flow
control construct
but throw is a flow control construct
and
you expect your flow control to be
correct irregardless of the context
in which it's evaluating however the
contract
of with local settings is
that the third argument must evaluate
because that's got your cleanup which
has to run which is why you're running
with local settings
right so i mean think that i think
that's why it seems like it's probably
the right behavior right you're right so
so the test that i bel i believe it was
tom it might have been
jeremy i apologize for not remembering
who but somebody proposed to test that
is it internal to the code or is it
external
those are my terms yes uh
um so people talk about synchronous
and asynchronous exceptions and
something like a control c
or time constraints are
kind of like asynchronous exceptions so
they're exceptions that come from
outside of the environment and throw and
catch
are synchronous exceptions within the
thread of execution
yes there's a subtlety with abort
the you know you type in abort open
close bracket
that is inside not external
but we several of us believe it should
behave like the external ones you
mentioned
exactly and i think it's even i think
that's even how it's documented
i i i think that's super important yeah
and actually it's a pity we don't
document time constrained as
like you know when the time runs out
it's as though control c was pressed
i think we do we sort of do not
sort of not 100 explicitly all right so
let's let me understand what you're
proposing so first of all
uh okay what what do you think is wrong
with the current with cleanup
uh i i i don't well so the consensus
seem to be
that the design is right but that these
notes are wrong okay because
right because uh
i don't think interrupt belongs on this
list
and the the
the the statement that uh
control transfers generated and init and
cleanup are effectively postponed until
the execution of these expressions is
complete
that's only true for the
uh sort of asynchronous
uh ones for abort time constraint memory
constrained
whereas throw and catch and i think
these others
though we'll need to actually do some
testing
behave like throw and all of them behave
i think
so then what you're saying is
the first
so there's a category here abort an and
interrupt
and interactive input like this
right right and then there's
these things which you think are
separate
um
i'm just going to move this because i
think that the right thing to do is
document that first
that's good and then this one
oh god what the heck happened there
i think you didn't quite select the the
the right column
and so it uh
but no that's really weird
well somebody else i can fix it i can
fix up the formatting if that's what
you're worried about that's what i'm
worried about
okay all right so now
right and the first two categories
should behave more or less exactly the
same
they don't although there's a pull
request open to try to fix that that
won't
go into twelve two but okay fine but
okay so then what do we say here
control transfers generated in it and
clean up
okay generated buy
which ones of these buy aborts you're
right by aborts
and um by
boats and
i mean arguably interrupt if you go into
an interrupt and you press the abort
button it's effectively in a board
like it's the same thing right so you
know what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna do this i'm gonna say
oh come on
okay i'm gonna say aborts
um
terminations what's that constraints
okay and what's the third category
called
control transfers
or exceptions exceptions is
really controlled transfers okay
the following types of operations
it's not really that blocked the
following types of operations
are modified
[Music]
um um
behavior
are modified interact with
no it's because they don't they don't
happen in
no they do somewhat though because for
example this is the example with throw i
don't know if you
if you look at i think it's on the left
somewhere right
the if the second input in my exam or
the first input in my examples
so you have throw and then print of one
and that those are both in the first
argument but the print of one never
happens because the throw
successfully escaped the first argument
right
sorry say that again i just so just look
at the
the first example on the left right
because this is a bit of a weird case
so note that the one that does not get
printed right so the first argument
of the with local settings is a compound
expression with a throw
and the print of one so the throw does
fire because print of one
one is never printed but it does it's
but it is sort of delayed to at least
allow three
the print of three and the third
argument to evaluate
i see but note this is different with a
board so if you look at the abort
example it does print one there's still
an abort though
notice as well right the board happens
but it finishes running in it
okay following types of operations are
blocked in various ways
correct good yes
okay so this should be
i bought an interactive interrupts and
then this
is itself what's that
and maybe also interrupt
except right that's yeah
i mean you could think of interrupt as
just being abort but
well except i don't because it brings up
a menu for me and that menu is not
blocked in any way
right if if you just saying blocked in
various ways here
right but but but see the only thing
that's blocked
well actually i don't know what happens
if you choose say enter dialog
but for example so we should test what
actually happens but
right now the only thing i know for sure
that it's modified is that
if you click on abort in the dialog
then it'll behave just like any other
abort
okay all right so let's document this so
then
um let's say what are we going to say
here
in
so aborts
is it correct aborts are effectively
postponed no
that's not i'm so confused yes aborts
are effectively
postponed
yes aborts in are effectively postponed
until the execution of these expressions
is complete
but no evaluate the expressions
it's still if an abort happens if any of
these happen pretty much
it doesn't evaluate the body anymore
yeah but it doesn't say that it says
initial
cleanup this this is good no wait a
minute i think i think aborts
during is but probably better than in
okay aborts during it and during the
evaluation
of aborts encountered
the ports executed during the evaluation
control c is not you know
right encountered or initiated but not
executed
let's just say during fine
during the evaluation of the net
and clean up
wait a minute i don't understand that
statement i mean
the abort
what happens in this case the abort the
board
is postponed until uh
the the init is done executing
then it's temporarily live
and so the printf2 is interrupted
and then you execute cleanup and at the
end of cleanup it's
reissued or made live again
um
if an abort is if it
is encountered
is initiated it's postponed until you
finish evaluating that argument
right is is it but then it's also
postponed
no but it doesn't no wait a minute is is
initiated during the evaluation
of uh
init then exper is not
evaluated
well the way one way you can think about
it although maybe this is a little
unclear for the documentation
is that it is evaluated but that the
first thing that happens is that the
abortions
right right right the first one gets rid
of this initiative during the
evaluation of a net um
it is postponed it is not immediately it
is not
immediately acted upon
though um
and exper is not evaluated
but cleanup is
that true yes yes
okay it is um perhaps a better way to
say it
is is to say it is not acted upon
until uh
init is fully evaluated
and then exper is not evaluated but
cleanup
is that's what i said okay i think
i'm just being a bit more explicit that
it's but
um okay so then the next case if a
constraint
is
okay wait a second so so
okay actually we need to say a different
thing here we need to say
um if an abort is initiated
during the evaluation of expert
that evaluation is aborted
but cleanup
is still executed
if an abort is initiated during the
evaluation of cleanup
um they're bought as postponed
until
the evaluation of cleanup is complete is
that right yep
yep yep
okay now what happens in the next case
if a constraint
so those should be modulo bugs
uh constraints should be handled the
same way as
boards correct constraints
but noting that you know i don't know if
this has to be send the documentation
if you put a constraint so the whole
constraint is inside of a knit
or clean up then it works as it normally
does it's only if
the constraint is outside
oh this is important yes yeah yes so
external constraints are treated as
right as just as a board's internal
constraints behave normally
or something constraints external
constraints
such as time constrained
well you already named the constraints
and you didn't name the board
above so you probably shouldn't say such
as no but i need to say this because
it's got to say
dot dot dot with cleanup
[Music]
dot dot dot dot dot external constraints
um that trigger or are reached
such as um
constraints generated externally
generated externally through
constructs such as
behave in with cleanup
like aborts
correct okay now
final case
um okay so control transfers
what is the control channel what happens
so so what what
is true is that
if a control control transfer
is initiated in any of the three
arguments
the evaluation of that argument
is immediately stopped
but a cleanup will evaluate
before but if it's in one of the first
two arguments
cleanup will evaluate before uh
you know the control transfer is
completed okay it won't stop
necessarily it will respect the transfer
if the transfer stays within the section
that
it's encountered right yeah if it was
caught
okay is that true both in init and exper
yes wait no not expert expert just has
normal behavior right i mean well so
does it if it's within if a control
transfer
occurs during the evaluation if the
current transfer
outside of if if if a control transfer
that whose destination
is outside
with cleanup with cleanup
occurs within
um init or exper is that right
yep
wait sorry is it knit or expert or knit
or cleanup
expert the
evaluation of cleanup is started before
the transfer is complete
well it goes within the transfer
is postponed
transfer
your language with abort is quite good
you have
three statements i quite like that
a bit more verbose but well i don't
think we need three here because i think
it's only
that the transfer if a control transfer
is destination is outside occurs within
init or the transfer is
is postponed not immediately acted upon
until after is postponed
until
this is actually true even if it is
initiated in uh
cleanup well but except this sentence
doesn't make sense
until uh uh
in with respect to because it still
makes sense
hold on within transfer and outside of
clean up until you're done with cleanup
no that's not true if it's in cleanup
and you transfer control it won't
evaluate the rest of cleanup it'll
terminate cleanup
okay because within the transfer is
postponed
until that's true of throw but is it
true of uh
something like go to or break problems
uh well that that's why i said we'll
have to check all of these cases
whose destination is outside because
with internet
the transfer
um is also the issue of return which
wait
does it finish doing init or not it does
not
that that's the whole point that i see i
see i see the transfer
the the the evaluation
then a network expert the evaluation of
init
of init or exper
is terminated
then
um the cleanup cleanup is evaluated
and then the transfer occurs
that is correct
and i don't know if we need to say this
explicitly but if we want to we can say
that if a control transfer occurs
during cleanup the the transfer is
immediate
okay i know i think we should say that
okay
just a little concerned that that might
only be true of throw
it really needs checking okay
showing the evaluation of cleanup
um it is not postponed
all right just as a note i was just
trying a bunch of these we're going in
it looks like the behavior of return is
actually kind of bizarre and probably
wrong
yeah everything with return is wrong um
yeah yes christopher
sorry yes to both it is bizarre
and wrong yes it is also very difficult
to change it
i tried once i see
you can break a lot what i think we
could do
is change it in the limited um
don't realm of when it occurs inside of
with local settings
by the way i've got two points one thing
is we think there is a new function
that is some kind of generalized return
that should be implemented but we're not
going to talk about that today
second question is do we really like the
name with cleanup it is not sitting with
me as happily as i would like it to
uh i don't like it but i don't have a
better one
i mean we thought about cleanly
it's sort of set up and tear down or
transaction or
well it isn't just that because i think
christopher has pointed this out it's
actually a useful thing
in just writing code where what's the
case
where you basically want what is the
case
well it's yeah i mean we talked about
this
it's basically there's a common idiom of
like uh
you run something then you run some
usually clean up and then you return the
first thing
oh that's right that's right that's
right it's like it's it's
it's like if you have code that you know
deals with a
file stream or something almost always
what you do is you
you uh you know you close the stream but
then you have to use a variable
to then return the thing that you read
in right so the basic point is that it
returns exper
it's just that it's useful even beyond
the fact that it does
fancy stuff with handling exceptions
right so the basic point is that it's
like
it's like an afterthought a forethought
and an afterthought
a preface an epilogue
what about with hooks
with hooks yeah as in like an
initialization hook
and a de-initialization hook i don't
think anybody's gonna understand that i
think that's that that has the same
you know that that's the um um
yeah i mean i mean something like
control controlled evaluation
or no i don't think we want controlled i
mean we want um
you know if there was a name like that
that was more like preface
epilogue or some such other thing
there's also a guarantee with this
i know there is but the guarantee is
less
i mean the point that we're trying to
get across is christopher's point which
i think i would use a lot
which is you just write a random piece
of code and it needs cleanup
right and and you don't want people to
be thinking oh this is an abort
protection critical section you know
blah blah blah blah blah blah
that's what makes it allow well i
understand that it bulletproofs it but
the point about it is
what we're trying to do is give it a
name so that even a random
you know programmer who isn't thinking
about bulletproofing
directly doesn't even think of
bulletproofing uses this construct and
by the way they get bulletproofing
so i'm saying so this is a a thing where
it's
i mean and with cleanup i think is okay
in terms of
indicating that it might be something
but i just don't i think it's rather an
elegant name um
i've always thought of this as similar
to the finale clause and i don't know
yes that that's that's what i was going
to say but
but i don't know how to make a good name
out of that
i mean finally is the wrapper around the
cleanup here
exactly
except this setup is is useful
and i'm not sure that clean is
necessarily the right thing it's just
that they're set up and tear down
that's true not even necessarily set up
right okay so what is a a metaphor for
something where there is
set up and tear down as opposed to just
wait maybe if it's a transaction nobody
will understand the word transaction
well yeah yeah but
just hear me out i mean it all happens
or none of it happens
that's that's the idea yeah but it
doesn't even it's neither true nor i
mean the concept of a transaction
um
right that that i would feel like that
would imply that any side effect
inside of exper would be rolled back
if expert didn't finish there's some
sort of guarantees
on emission cleanup of automaticity
right
atomic evaluate
so i was reviewing some of our notes
from previous discussions and we
at one point we were calling this
protected evaluate
i don't think that was terrible i don't
think it's great either
it just doesn't get the point across it
it suggests this is all about critical
sections and so on
and we don't want to make that point we
want to make the point it's just
something that you use when you want to
evaluate something
but when you want things to happen
before and after that are irrelevant to
the value
i i think i disagree with that
characterization
the protected aspect is in fact critical
to to
success i i understand i understand but
but the point is okay here's the point
we can sell this to people so to speak
you know set up tear down finally you
know whatever else it is
the people who understand critical
sections or whatever you know
this is this is you know that's okay
the question is can we generalize the
appeal of this thing
to people who don't know about those
things who don't even think about or
what if it interrupts
the file closing operation okay but who
will then use it
just because they are trying to have
something which
you know does some cleanup and then by
the way their code will have less bugs
in it
if you see i'm still thinking atomic
evaluate might
partly get that across i don't see it i
think it's too much metaphor
i mean in other words the question is
what what does somebody think about when
they want to have they want to do an
evaluation
but they want some it's not side effects
it's kind of like like um
i mean it's run these two things and
give me the first
yeah right or run these three things and
give me the middle
so i was going to suggest middle
evaluate not particularly
seriously
which is long
no should be something nice and short i
mean it would be great if it was a
single word
i think first then is interesting but i
agree it's also kind of
too weird it's way too weird
okay
isn't terrible
enclosed we already have right
well we already haven't clo hold and
close that
and close family wasn't wrapped evaluate
once
proposed
yes but bookended is the first one that
i think is interesting it's just a
a bit it's just a little bit kind of
weirder
that coda c-o-d-a
but you have to explain it to all of us
is a bad sign
yeah i i i understand it i understand it
too
but evaluate after
or before and after one thing that's
nice about bookended
it isn't quite right it needs to be
something that that kind of concept is
right
something with ends to it something that
has had
has had you know a thing
that's had a container with its ends put
on it what do you call a cylinder that
has its um
in mathematics what is it when when you
know an open cylinder was a closed
cylinder no that's bad
you know a capped itself isn't right but
something like this
yeah something that has says ends on it
as opposed to not
um
let's see and what's that is there a
middle version of epilogue and prologue
or is it just a log or dialogue
entry log
[Music]
midlog
sandwiched is wrong because it
is the sandwich is just too weird anyway
[Music]
uh how about blt'd instead i mean
that sounds yummy bookend is too
whimsical
capped is too incomprehensible but
something in the middle of those will be
good
what do you do i mean what the heck is
is um um
and this won't work but bounded
something
yes that's a good idea that's something
like that
well okay just just to you know it seems
like they're the they're the ones where
it's on either end like bookended and so
on and then the ones where it's only at
the end
like epilogue or coda or something which
i think
would also be fine you can use one
bookend
what was the thing that you just
suggested i'm sorry i wasn't i
well there's an epilogue which is taken
but the concept i think is pretty good
and there was someone suggested coda
earlier
but they're probably other words that
basically mean the same thing
what about the limited
evaluate
they're limited i don't think is right
don't we've got a two minute that's too
weird delimited has delimiters in the
middle as well
um and we're already using it but you
know it could be something like framed
or
i think that suggests the frame is there
i think the the whole point is that
that the thing you really want
capped the problem with capped is that
it's like a cap on something
is like holding it you know it's putting
a cap on it like an oil well
it sounds a little bit like you're
constraining it yeah
it also sounds like a graphics construct
it sounds like how it works
to my mind
except for the fact that it feels very
static i mean bookended
it's like set up and tear down
it's like what do you say about an
an event that has a beginning middle and
end
[Music]
abridged tragedy since it's only has
three acts rather than five
huh
intro outro
or maybe just outro i mean again i think
that that it's
maybe just figuring out a name for the
first usage line
might be easier than the second
nobody will ever understand outro it
looks like some kind of weird
food yeah is that even a word i don't
know i don't think so when has that ever
stopped us
suggesting buttressed i think that's
again too whimsical um but something
like that has got to be right
let's go triad what's that
evaluate triad
no way it's some kind of ancient greek
mythology thing
triadic evaluate try evaluate i still
like
yeah um recently afterward
or like like afterward with an o like
epilogue
so uh the the thesaurus is giving
me supported embraced as synonyms
for bookended and and but and buttressed
about fenced or pinned
afterwards is a bit like coda right yep
yeah i mean both have their
point here coda i'm i
maybe i'm just ill-educated but coda
just doesn't i don't know what the
it's this thing like like it's at the
end of your piece of music there's a
coda where it's sort of you know
it's just like a conclusion thing where
it comes back to some previous
bit inclusion well with that but that
but doesn't it go back to a previous bit
that's the problem
no that's only if it's a da capo so the
capo al coda means
go to the beginning and end and and
don't repeat the code up but there's
also
uh just plain coda which is an appendage
i see like a stop code on except it's
not yes exactly
something with post you see
i mean coderd
but that's just unbelievably weird
because it's not this thing is not the
coda
this thing is
you see it's better to be something dead
after worded but that's too weird as
well
um finally
or something like that well
unfortunately resolved this means
something completely different
and finally isn't the right part of
speech
um
see result the result it's not that the
um backed
back ended back ended no
clamped no
layered stepped
with afterthought
i'm also you know so the generalization
that we're talking about now
sort of reminds me a little bit about
compound expression you know it's
related getting to be you know sort of
a stricter version or something
yeah but it isn't the same thing because
expression returns the last element and
also
the name it was one of those places
where we were smart enough to realize
the name
compound expression right right um
hey speak for yourself i type it in full
form sometimes
yeah occasionally brian
scaffold scaffolded unfortunately
unfortunately that that is a nice word
but i think it means too many other
different things
bumper yeah something like that except
just
bumper is just too freaking weird
but that's just like like that like
there we have two of them and they're
crashing into each other at the park i
mean my other weird one was
that i suggested was caboose
yeah ethan is suggesting when done the
problem is
the problem is that's emphasizing the
peace that
um
i think that's not too bad an ultimate
what pen ultimate
what's pen about it next to last but
right right well yes because it's
returning the next to last thing so
penultimate is in fact
exactly correct but it kind of implies
there could be more than three
yeah it's weird i don't understand when
done
because when done so we would say when
done
expert comma cleanup i think it means
quite the right thing because we want to
explain that it's doing extra
well when it's done it's it's doing
cleanup
but but it's still returning expert to
you so in that sense when done
i don't think it's bad when done i don't
get it i just don't get it i mean
um well here's the question right i mean
what are you going to put in the second
argument other than some piece of
cleanup
because then the question is why is you
know we should compare all these with
the name with cleanup
right i agree with cleanup is not other
than the inelegance of it
the fact that it seems messy um
tidy up
tightly when done is that the same as
completed
that would just look so weird in a piece
of code tidally but it's nice it's very
british
and i and i and right it has a little
bit of the
impression of of you know
safe evaluation because you're making
your code you know you're ensuring your
code is all tidy
but without necessarily coming right out
and screaming that
yeah what's better than i mean cleanly
would say that would do the same thing
and be more elegant than with cleanup
but it's less clear what the hell it
means
do you know it always used to amuse me
that the translation of you know
uh keep america beautiful that slogan
the british translation was keep britain
tidy
um with cleanup doesn't look so terrible
compared with these things
any of these well
it's it's not obscure
yes on the other hand that's good
it's not a name we might use somewhere
else well that's true too
um
i don't think this is really i think
cleanup is better than with
with coda is too weird and somehow it
reminds me of
i don't know what um
i don't know where i'm even saving this
hold on a second i want to save these
yeah i mean a lot of these you could
just add with to them like with
afterward or
without that's in the category of just
absurdly long
um
let's see
well right now with cleanup is looking
like the best one should we make it
experimental for now
that way we have a if we think of some i
mean i just don't
it bothers me well well i i mean it's
not ready to be implemented it's not
implemented so
i mean we could leave it i thought it
was implemented because
i thought it wasn't i mean i have a
kernel implementation of it
i haven't i haven't made a pull request
or anything for it because there was
some debate about
about stuff like this okay oh you do
have a colonel pull request ready
okay i i i i haven't i haven't committed
it so there is no pull request but i've
written the code
and all it is is it's just basically
with local settings but with a different
version for the two argument case
okay i mean that's probably right
why don't you why don't you put in the
portal question it seems like
we abandoned with local settings but um
you've got to be freaking kidding me
settings what's that
localized settings there's no settings
here no no no
that's is better
all right
with cleaning instead of clean up with
cleaning
no no
cleansed cleansed
you have been cleansed of all your sins
and the file is closed
all right
it just isn't a bit of an elegant name
it feels like a hacky name that's what
bothers me
i mean cleansed if it didn't have a lot
of stupid you know
baggage would be a reasonable name
maybe maybe i think i think i think i
would take cleanly over
cleansed yeah yeah
but cleanly is so obscure yeah
i agree but i think it's epsilon less
obscure than cleansed
cleanse i suggest it as a joke
you should know better than that by now
tom
um
i'm just i'm just looking at a thesaurus
again
you're my
hands this is just absolved which is uh
um
but how many hail marys do you need to
say
i i think an amusing one is wholesome
which gets across the idea of uh
never mind that's a stupid i mean it
just does get across the idea of an
atomic transaction
i mean i think that the relation between
this and
like there are two ways you can think of
this as being this atomic
thing and they're both a little weird
right
all right with cleanup it is let's go
with that
all right let's go on with our agenda i
might drop out now actually if that's
not too bad you might have a slight
interest in the next item but
if you want to go i i i will not hold
you hostage
what's the next item it's
a play a2 okay so i
i'm not needed right you are not
okay i'll head out i got another meeting
thanks thanks okay
bye all right so what are we doing here
right
so i mean i wrote this rough page so you
know
i want you to make sure you're okay with
it
um there is one specific question and we
also need to
knit it which i have not yet done reset
x to the results you mean s oh yes
that's a typo from a previous version
why do you want to say s wouldn't it be
clear to just say x here
uh i i originally had x but then i
noticed that
uh a pen to apply to
a append to add to all those guys seem
to be using s
so okay does it does it have to be a
symbol
so that is what the point i want to
to raise which is we don't explicitly
document it anywhere that it can be
anything other than the symbol
although there are these random examples
on some pages
which use it with it not being a symbol
what would be
it as in it's never been existed before
no no so on all of the
similar pages so add to subtract from
et cetera et cetera et cetera we only
document
the main usage and the notes and in fact
even the error messages for the most
part
only refer to it as being a symbol
okay however some of those pre-existing
pages
do have like application or other random
examples
where it's treated where you have a
first argument which is not a simple
plus equals or something right
so if you if you look at the ad to or i
certainly know that the pen too
if you look at that ref page there will
be i haven't even thought of this this
is quite nice that you can do
compositions like this
right it's and so in my last example
i uh you know
i i and so the question is this one here
yes could also even imagine doing things
like um
like with for example with plus equal
you can use uh
you you can give it like a list of two
symbols and it'll add to both of them
like you could also imagine doing
something like you could say list
um list x comma y equal
uh what is it at equals reverse and that
would be like a swap operation i think
what are you saying christopher what
unless you wrote something like x
list of you know like if you just had a
list
x comma y and x and y both had values
yes well even if they were just symbols
i mean they would also
i don't think that would work can't
possibly look at your symbols yes you're
right
so if x and y are values and you say
list x comma y
at equals reverse then it'll effectively
swap the values of x to y
wow is that really true let's see
i don't think it'll work in the way you
wrote it or maybe
yeah oh shocking okay
right because of part extraction
that's cool you should add that example
at all
okay and so then should we add a note to
this and all this
other pages saying that s doesn't have
to be
i think symbol as long as it's uh an
assignable
expression or some some verbiage like
that
okay
oh look the sander is commenting this is
an interesting thing
saying just used yesterday something
which says
okay list all comma two at
equals map of
norm
right your list doesn't have that depth
so
right no i understand that i have to
make a new list
um
my gosh
why does it need the map oh it needs the
map it was going to go another level so
if i just said at equals g oh no i see
that's not going to work that's not
going to work
you get a big massive g for everything
yeah
right i say map of g
huh yeah you might want to start over
that's very nice should also be in the
examples
right and if g was a map it was a
listable thing like
log or something yeah
um this might relate to tally's
new ideas that he's um
uh for
um
sort of broadcasting of stuff can
somebody make sure that they
show tally this this thing
yeah yeah i can make sure it gets passed
along
this is nice well there's some good
examples for you um
a tie but yes i think we should just we
should just document i mean this
this clearly sells it i mean this idea
right here clearly sells it
even if even if nothing else you know
the f of one thing
might or might not be worth doing but
this is clearly worthwhile
mm-hmm it's interesting
that's really quite interesting the
order in which it's written
like it has to be that way but it does
make it somewhat hard to read at least
at first
like the fact that x at equals f return
you know turns into f of x but i i don't
think that can really be helped
x equals f we mean returns f of x
itself its value the value of the at
equals itself is f
i'm just saying that basically the right
it's a little weird that you kind of
have the function after
the value you're applying it to but that
can't that
that yeah i understand well christopher
wants equal lap
exactly maybe or maybe uh
i mean another thing you could do but i
think this is also into obscures
slash slash equals
um because that might convey that
because at normally it's the function on
the left and the value on the right
slash it's this order but that might
look a little bit too much like division
actually that's not a silly suggestion i
mean
by the way i think slash equals is a
infix uh
operator it's like a monad operator in
haskell
you know i have to say i think slash
equals is better than that equals
it might be slightly more consistent but
i think it's also much weirder mainly
because it looks like division
and if it doesn't look like slash equals
then it also you know in some languages
double slashes like integer division and
stuff like that and people might
try this and then be totally shocked at
weird results i mean at equals has
a very nice parallel with plus equals
no it doesn't it's the opposite way
around
no
isn't it i mean but plus is commutative
so it doesn't
let's just slash equals okay so look
let's say let's say if we say
u equals um u equals eight or something
u slash equals
um seven
we get eight over seven we get points
operator is in the order you know left
and then right and so on
i i yeah
i i think i think slash equals is better
than that equals
i'm sorry i think it's it's um
it's more dangerous right because it's
sort of
overlapping an existing operator
um i'm not worried about that
everything's overlapping there's a
stopper
at equals it's overlapping at
you you mean it the fact that it has the
fact that it's
contained flash equals but yeah yes
but it doesn't seem terribly ambiguous
it contains slash eagles that contain
slash slash it contains equal sign
so what
as the person who hasn't looked at the
parser code in
30 years yes i understand
um all right i mean i'll need
i'll need both tom and john to weigh in
on if there's some issue we're missing
before we implement this
[Music]
um bob is
on a live stream is being confused for
exactly the reason we would expect
people to be confused about this
what what did he say it says if f equals
sign f at
equals three becomes sine of three but
it doesn't it becomes
three of f yeah okay
well three of sine
[Music]
um
this is much better slash equals
um
sandra is complaining that slash ash's
three characters look they're unshifted
characters at least on an english
keyboard
um oh talking of syntax you know i'm
actually very happy about the slash
equals i think it's a really good idea
this bothered me that it was the wrong
way round
so let it you should report on whether
there's a problem in implementing that
okay okay i want to bring up one more
thing so does anybody know what the
status of a vertical bar
arrow for function admit oh
did it just work it just worked
and look it's even properly colorized
because i pestered john about that
okay so i go this
okay so that's purple and then when i go
f
there oh i see and it has the correct
scoping
right and it was purple because you
didn't have a the right hand side right
if you delete the
f right it'll turn purple again even
though it will still be
a single unicode operator and and will
it work even if it's not like if it's
just the ascii
vertical bar dash greater than or does
it need yes
oh so in iraq so
in fact in i mean john is working on
this feature
where instead of literally replacing
sequences with
operators they just sort of look pretty
but there's still the ascii sequence
but because that feature isn't quite
ready
he put in the auto replacement but
if you very carefully type it in so that
it doesn't get
replaced or if you're in a raw kernel
the ascii
operator works by the way bob is
pointing out that he actually wasn't
confused he was just suggesting that
equals could work the other way around
okay the the
it was useful the potential of being
confused was useful to see
they've um i want to raise one more
thing about function
you guys may think i'm crazy but i am
thinking that we should just bite the
bullet after
30 whatever how long is it since 1935
how many years is that that's
a lot of years and we should just
support
we should actually support something
like this
okay well we don't have the right set of
people to discuss that
right i mean we don't have to do it
right now but i mean do you object
i think it'd be nice to support this i
mean there's enough notation
out there where people are using lambdas
it's clear what this means
i like the idea of using oh maybe i'm
not understanding what this the idea is
so you
you want a lambda operator it's just a
lambda operator it's yet another
notation for function
okay uh there's some languages that
already do this
like for example in in in haskell when
you write a lambda it's like a backslash
but you can also i think have okay some
unicode lambda thing
they're also languages like i know for
example in racket you can do this
um with subscript no
not with subscripts but thoughts i
suspect
with no i think like the way haskell
does it's just backslash and then
you know space separated values because
that's the hassle style of things
like like x y and then an arrow and so
on but
i think we should do this i think we
should commission a you know a
lambda character that does this i
don't see any reason not to i don't know
exactly what it's what it's binding
you know what the precedence should be
but it seems like you know
given that this was invented you know it
is so embarrassing that i have to do
this i
i'm i'm just outraged but i i could get
this right
85 years ago um
yes i actually how embarrassing
um right i mean uh right so
uh yeah i mean i i
have no objection i mean i have no deep
objection other than the
fact that it's you know extra
undoubtedly going to be extra work for
me
um the um
i haven't i don't have anything else to
do etai
yeah i know just like just like john i'm
spending all day taking naps because i
don't have enough to do
um but uh okay well let's let's just
but yeah but the only tricky bit will be
you know deciding on the correct
precedence
yes um because it's now a prefix
operator rather than either a postfix or
postfix or infix and would it need to be
a special
lambda or would it just be a normal
should be a special lambda i think
yeah i mean i'll double check but yeah
well it certainly can't be just plain
lambda um and i i mean
again this is the sort of research we
need to do like is there a
unicode character for lambda as used in
lambda calculus or will we need a
special
r yeah and that's who wanted double
struck or something like our other
operators there are two immediate
problems though the problem
one is uh you have a piece of text and
you don't know
hey is that lambda in the middle of a
function lambda or like
just symbol lambda right the other
problem is
if i you know if you're writing
something in some text editor
and then you import it and you were
trying to write function lambda but
really when you import it it turned into
just
mathematical you know greek letter
lambda
you know well that's why we need to know
whether there's a unicode character
but the point is that nobody knows that
no one necessarily is thinking of that
distinction
they just write a lambda and expect it
to interpret it as
uh well that's a question of traditional
form import because i don't think we can
well expect maybe complaining about this
as a concept i mean
i i it just seems like uh it makes it so
that first of all
you can't as a human reading the code
you can't tell what's going to happen
because you don't know what type of
lambda it is and then so that's why it
has to be
it would have to be a double struck
lambda of some kind
okay right the rendering in the front
end will definitely not
be just a plain lamb that'll be a double
struck or right just like exponential e
is easy to tell apart from a normal
lowercase e um
and and and exponent and imaginary i
is clearly distinguishable from i then
although although at the same time it
does kind of take away from it because i
think that
you know the point of supporting this is
because it's sort of a common
notation and it looks kind of nice and
if you make it this kind of
you know ugly ugly lambda that it might
not be
as nice but yeah
well we can yeah i mean i think we
should
i i let me put it
i yes and and there are various
those are among the things we'll need to
consider i i'm i i totally agree that
discussion is not done and and maybe
if we think about it a bit more we might
discover a reason why it's not worth the
trouble
but uh it's obviously not going to be
trivial to enter you're going to have to
type you know escape
something to get the lambda but
um i mean i don't think that's
devastating by the way sander uh
kindly made a bunch of suggestions for
see also
for apply to um i told you want to pick
these up
some place uh um maybe if you can just
save this notebook somewhere where devin
can get it to me or or send it to me
after the meeting
the whole notebook i'm not i don't just
say but but i'll send you
actually sure why not i'll just say that
no let me save it that's what i thought
was going to happen
i'll just say because there were also
all those examples in there so
oh well okay well then let me save this
notebook sorry
by the way about the issue of precedence
presumably the precedence for it should
be
the same as the infix operator you just
look at the right-hand side right
that's that would be my initial guess
but i i i have learned not to that
that guessing is is insufficient the
hard way
so i will not commit to that
i really like this though what happens
by the way how do these associate
uh it's the opposite of equal so
um i think it does currying
like it does occurring by default right
if you do x
yeah beautiful
right it should be documented yes
wait a minute is that currying by
default let me just understand that so
that if i go
this thing a
a of b and then instead of z
right you know right right i have to
write f
change
yes oh that's beautiful
but i can't take the parentheses away
can i
no i don't know
that should be an example because
because obviously
uh it would be very bad if if the
brackets
there if f did not pull in the brackets
right so
there's no way that you you we can make
the parents optional
although that doesn't uh this is my
least favorite example of precedence
which is
uh the what is it pattern test
which has yeah
okay okay good all right um
oh while we're at it let's go to this
one next
this one is a this one is a sort of
trivial but i it's kind of
frustrating to me and i think we should
change it
okay see that i have no idea why that's
a one character size
why did we do that why is why is two-way
rule
not longer i just whenever i use it just
bothers me
how long is undirected edge
how do i even get undirected escape d e
escape
oh can you do e okay well that's a
directed
edge yeah that's a bit longer isn't it
yeah it looks like so i think yeah crazy
is that long enough or did you want even
longer
i think a tiny bit longer than that but
of order that length
that length would be okay if th i think
that would be okay
if that just had an arrow thing on it i
think that will be okay
i mean if you can mock it up we can we
can know for sure but that looks more or
less okay this is just too short here
okay sounds good um it's because i do
need to look at it at normal size not
yes let's do that
no well now you wouldn't set a
you want you could also try undirected
edge but it's probably the same as
directed edge
hopefully oops
what's up
think so might be anti-aliasing
yeah no they look the same like yeah
they should be the same
okay well that guy is just anomalously
short and should be fixed
um sandra is pointing out something
about greening
for for um uh
okay so these go oops i need to go
vertical bar it's a little bit weird to
type but
so should that be
should the c what color should that c be
i think if i listen
it's not bound to anything so it is
if that then oops if now i go
um f of abc then those green correctly
yeah i mean it should just have the same
exact coloring diffuse function
yeah okay
okay that was that um
let's skip this for now given i just
want to explain what it is
i just want to explain what it is and
then we'll wrap it up in some i mean
the um
um
this is to do with when you do rasterize
and other things like that
do they leave white space what leaves
white space and what does not
like if i say graphics of disc
okay i get something which is got a
little bit of white space i think
around there am i you're right i'm not
right uh two percent black range padding
okay so if i said plot range padding
arrow zero
i see then there's none there okay
if i then say rasterize
of that
it's tight
well maybe this is a documentation issue
i don't know so now
now do the same thing with try the same
thing just for fun i don't
know if this will change anything with
image size goes to five on the original
graphic
five something that small yes
why is it so tall yeah that's just seems
completely wrong
right and so i think that's the thing
that was coming up in that mail thread
is that
yeah that just seems utterly utterly
wrong but try
try do do this delete the app itself
first
how can that make it registerize i don't
think it will make a difference you
should look but it's still tall
the tallness is completely crazy well
then look is the original graphics tall
like if you just click
graphics is it tall yeah
right yeah i mean right i mean
it has something to do with you know
sort of what the
what the heck is going on here
you're making this you're making the
cell tall and the
and the graphics has an explicit image
size so it's not going to grow with
the cell around it but you're telling me
if i look at this thing
and i say for example if i said magnify
of this
10.
okay so it's a rasterized problem right
well
that that's because uh right because you
can't just
rasterize a box right it needs to go
into a cell
otherwise it can't resolve everything
and
so it's because that is taller or
you know less tall than the
um this looks like a bug to me
maybe the behavior may be rasterized
should have special behavior when given
a graphics object as opposed to just a
general
you know expression yes possibly
all right well then so if we're talking
specifically about rasterize then we can
bring in the relevant folk yeah okay i
mean it looks
this is clearly a very bad case
and that may be what has burned me yet
go ahead i just rasterized for things
where it's like oh yeah you know i have
some
i have like uh a bunch of polygons and i
want to make them to rasters and do
image operations on them and stuff like
that
and then you sort of rely on the fact
that like in this case i have like a
maps you sort of rely on the fact that
you render it as a graphics and you
rasterize it
and that the position rendered it on the
graphics you know
the in the resulting raster that you
know the you can you can properly
project back and and stuff like that and
and if it if it's secretly
or if it's moving stuff around a tiny
bit then you're kind of breaking this
well so you said wait a minute wait are
you objecting to the
i mean what the behavior right now seems
completely wrong and seems the result of
as as as it i have said of the
boxification of these things
before rasterization
correct right know so the the space that
you see is coming from
the cell height which is completely
crazy
right because there's no cell in sight
you know all i did was to say rasterize
the graphic
right i mean in in general you do want
to do that because
obviously right yeah but right if but if
you want if you
want the the raster to actually follow
you know the styles of the style sheet
that you may have then you need to stick
it in a cell
you know with the styles or you'll end
up with oh gosh that's right but
the styles can flow into the graphic
right
well okay i think i think and now we're
getting to the point where we need john
or giulio
or somebody who knows more about the
spotlight
what's that does brett know that
not off the top of my head now okay fine
but basically we've now identified what
the problem is the problem is this
why don't you guys talk about this
whether this is just a bug and could be
fixed
and then um uh if that
is um if it isn't just a bug then we
need to talk about it some more
sounds right i mean i was going to say i
could imagine that this
has some effect on like how things get
you know if we do bitmaps for
html export sorts of things
for inline formulas and whatnot
that you know changing the behavior of
rasterize could have an effect there
sorry sorry sorry but sorry one thing
is sander is saying is the fact that
that
final a is green correct or not
sure it's it's inside the function that
contains just like if you did function
of a comma a
i see okay fine so it will pick up
that
yeah that's
boy that's a weird thing
actually i should carry it what's that
if you're commenting about the b dollar
sign you can do really weird stuff like
for example if you
define a function you know that just
calls module with its you know arguments
unchanged
it'll have different behavior with that
dollar signing and stuff like that you
know the fact that this has been so
confused ever since i was looking at
church's original paper just recently
and it was already confused there
i think everybody should just use
combinators
good luck i think we are going to we are
going to find a way to rehabilitate
combinators
they're going to be 100 years old this
december it's time to rehabilitate them
i admit that they are very you know the
the human story of combinators is not
good
humans don't understand combinators very
well
um
oh boy bob is pointing out if raster has
an em it will have the same space as a
g that's probably true right now
which is probably not a bad thing that's
another issue we should make a
a note of that issue of making sure that
if you rasterize like
right now if i say let's see if i say
rasterize
style of of um i don't know 30 or
something
yes it is a good feature that those all
line up
you didn't you didn't do it right you
need to put the rasterize inside of the
map
right oh i was very confused yes
and they still line up right now but
they're not graphics objects so i think
that's correct i think graphics objects
are the case where
they shouldn't it doesn't matter about
whether they line up it matters that
they be pixel
correct i think
i think you're probably right although i
suspect we're going to need an option
that determines which of these it does
i also think that the headroom what's
the option for
like framed on whether it does a tight
frame margins no same thing with content
content margins there there is
i think so and right there
uh there's a
there are a few different margins
there's frame margins
and content padding
that's the one
which i mean i think that may be a
closer analogy but it's been a while
since i've looked at it
fair enough okay we should look at this
um
okay question there's a comment here
which is
not so relevant to this but it's a good
comment is speaking of color
content coloring for notebook context
variables
that's probably a bug that those are
black
when you have notebooks which are right
you know what i'm talking about yes um
if i set this the number one user of
those is docs
i mean those are right yes actually
smaller granularity than the notebook
but
you mean no you want the notebook's
default context
unique to this notebook
well then then i'm i'm having i mean
give fff a
value yeah
i had never thought of the system before
does one wants a different color for
that i mean i do agree that having
something which is
which but the problem is for
documentation you don't want a different
color because
well that's a good it's a good idea well
i mean but
why is the notebook context really any
different from global
right it's something that's on context
path
and and has a value so
it's just that notebooks global well
fair enough fair enough
look really this will get fixed when we
have finally the notebook toolbar
and we can indicate and it's something
we should make sure it's in the notes
for that i'm sure we have that but we
should check
that in the toolbar if the notebook has
a unique context
the toolbar should should indicate that
context
see what i'm saying devon
did you get that yep note
okay actually so here's the
interesting idea i'll put out there i'll
put out there that
if the notebook has a notebook context
set
that symbols in global should be colored
differently yes that's right
they should be
they should be
yeah that's a good point
even though it's on the context path
well it's not at that point is it
oh i see right is saying that in the
settings you can set a color for global
variables but not for notebook variables
we have the wrong people in this meeting
to talk about this there's a good topic
but we have the wrong people for it
and sander who seems to be a major
proponent of
of slash equals which is really good is
commenting that apply to should
should have a link in functional
programming in the guide page and
the syntax guide page yes that is a
correct piece of knitting but we're not
going to do it right the second
um i just want to ask the question
given that christopher understands what
this now what this application thing
does
do we think that there's a a connection
with a slash
type thing here in other words if this
do you understand what this application
thing oh i know because it does go in
the at
order it's just it goes in the at order
right
and um so i i think this should just be
a filled
you know these combinator books they
mostly
these days use a a large filled black
circle for this um
so this is uh what would it be such
overloaded operation especially okay
first of all there's a thing called
center dot
i i i know that but but what they're
using is um
the large fill circle you mean
or small or small filled circle well
no they're using something intermediate
probably in size between filled circle
and full
small filled circle i mean small may not
be as small as you think it is
there isn't a small felt circle though
yeah it's probably comparable to this
maybe this is what we should use i just
don't think this half moon thing is
working
in that context it looks like a pair of
eyes looking to the side
yes is the is the physical size it was
just
filled in would that work
i think so the small circle is a little
bigger
well i think this size filled in would
work okay
yeah and i think and i think it's good
that it's a slightly different size even
though it'll be hard to tell
i mean the only really the only way
you'll be able to tell them apart but
is by math spacing right one has
operator spacing and the other does not
but look the only thing that's bad about
this
okay the original papers on combinators
this was just
you know abutment so to speak there was
no indication
of anything so it's kind of annoying to
have to put in something which is a very
very heavy
indicator but you know we're 100 years
later and you're saying it was
pre-literate programming
well yes it was before anybody ever
thought the programming right and so
they
their assumption was i mean i got to
show you something and and
okay you want to see something just
mildly entertaining
arguably you know another part of quotes
bringing into the modern era
is making it right associative oh but
once you make it right associative
you've lost the whole point is we've got
right associative it's that sign
we don't need no exactly that's what i
mean i mean i'm saying that that
arguably another part of taking it to
the modern era apart from
adding an infix uh is is
making it right associative because
that's how everything in modern times
released mathematica works
no but this is not the case because
right as a
write associative means function of an
expression gives an expression and here
we need
that function of an expression gives
another function
so that's why it's it's associated to
the other side
okay i i guess i'm observed thinking
about it i mean does this actually let
you express things
okay right i i guess you're right this
does actually let you express things
that you you you couldn't
without parentheses you could not write
this in right associative way
so yes you're right exactly yes so this
is much nicer to carry
because you can have f of x is another
function
that applies on y that applies etc
and you don't need any parentheses
i'll show you something just for fun i
can pull it up
um stephen i i was thinking that perhaps
it should be gray then
so that it imitates the the phantom
times yeah that would be nice that's a
good idea
well but would it be a phantom thing or
would it only be
i mean presumably it should be black if
you actually type it and then only gray
if it were some phantom thing like the
phantom times but i don't think there's
any idea of making this like the phantom
times is there
um no i don't think it's phantom
yeah it's not fanta but
i i was thinking about the stephen's
comment on
this shouldn't be there it should be
white so perhaps if it's this great
it feels but how can we make it oh i see
but just making it gray
as a way to phantomize it so to speak
exactly
it will be less heavy i think that will
be a reasonable idea here i'm just going
to show you one thing here
um this is uh it's a better resolution
version of this
oh gosh why is this happening this is
happening in twelve two i've got an
image which admittedly is very big
but i'm getting um okay so this
is church's original notes from when he
discovered sean finkel's paper and what
really
amused me to no end look at that look at
that
look at that that's our friendly at sign
but being used for presumably left
associative function
well look at look at this case here what
is he doing here what is he doing is he
confused
why did he even write a symbol i mean i
thought with a lot of this commenter
stuff they don't even write the symbol
because that's all they're doing
well the question is why is he bothering
to write okay
identity function i have x equals x
oh in his notation he says i hadn't read
this before
i at sine x
so what is he doing here so
we will have a combinator i which is the
identity
no i understand that i'm not asking
about that i'm asking about how he's
doing the function
application here which one is he
seems like he's just translating it
seems like this whole note is it's just
him saying
here's one notation without signs here's
the same notation without signs
okay but in this case here this is left
associative right 5x
chi of x is he's writing this
that's left associate yeah right he's
outside his left associative as opposed
to above
when i'm not sure what associative it is
even right
what the hell is he doing here
this is um hey what notation does shaun
finkle use
he doesn't have he has no character
there he just says cxy so why does
church write in his notation
or or maybe he's referring to someone
else no it says no
my notation that means that's that's
curry writing it
right so he's introducing the symbol
why well because he had a
he claims although we're in the process
of trying to get this from the curry
archive
he claims that he had see this is very
conveniently date stamped november
28 1927. um
and uh you know he claims that he had a
i mean
look fundamentally calling this currying
is completely wrong
even church calls it says that this is
you know
a schoenfinkel idea and it wasn't
but anyway this is sean finkling has
quite the same ringtone i know i know
i know various people have pointed this
out i am going to track down
how the computer science community ended
up calling it currying because this is
quite
um uh um
the uh
um
let's see uh pioneers commenting where
to find this is this is curry's original
papers not sean finkel
i don't have sean finkel's papers
although i am i am homing in
on i i know an awful lot about sean
finkel now
and i'm i haven't um uh
um but for example church
in um here's
we're going off into something
irrelevant here but i mean church
i mean i can show you just huge amount
of stuff about about um
this is church's original paper
oh no this is the book calculated lambda
conversion
which by the way is just full of utter
utter
bizarre complication about this the same
thing that's been a confusion for 85
years about the renaming of variables
in lambdas wait but by the way
the paper in the back the the brown one
with the ath sign
that's is that you first said it was
church and then you said it was curry
whose is it i'm sorry it's curry this is
curry i did if i said church i
was said the wrong thing but so then in
in curry's papers does he ever use the
sat sign again or is it just in this
note
that is a very good question which i
should know the answer to in fact i can
pull it up and we can answer that
question
um bizarrely curry's first paper
on commentators was published in
american journal but written in german
which journal is this um journal of
american math society i think
i think it's american journal of
mathematics 1930.
so this is now um i mean
i have no idea why he did this every
other issue every other paper in this
issue is in
is in english um but
uh haskell is british isn't
curry no curry is american curry curry
haskell curry is an american who
uh is is the whose parents founded what
is now
curry college well
critically um the place where the summer
school was several years ago
that's right that's right and curry but
curry
no that was curry's parents and
originally it was called the school of
expression
and it was a rhetoric and languages
school
um but uh okay so this is
this is um this is curry okay so now
here
he's talking about there's currying
which sean finkel gives a better version
of i have to say i think
if we look at the schoenfinkel paper
uh where is it um
oh gosh so he writes no symbol
well in this case here he's writing no
symbol but let's take a look well here
yeah there he's writing nothing and
there he writes
i love the way that he's using blanks or
something here what is he doing he's
doing
one i mean essentially they're blanks
but they're
like m dashes or something well right
but i mean it's the same notation
as some uh
this paper is other than the fact that i
can see vicious circle principle
anybody hear me german not well
i i was gonna say german is the language
that you don't know
if i remember correctly yeah i don't
know yeah
um so forgive the interruption but we
did have another item there yeah let's
look
sort of important for 12.2 okay brett
um dude hopefully it'll be quick we just
need a name
okay fine that's famous lost
i was just gonna say that
buddha i'm just gonna show you one thing
the english translation
well let's see what he uses
oh this is quine's introduction
this is a very clean paper the sean
finkel paper
it's the most understandable version of
combinators
well here we go okay he seems to write
basically the exact same thing
as curry yeah like with that exact
expression verbatim is in curry exactly
i mean he's just showing his left
associative but
which is nice that he that he does that
very cleanly
i mean he then goes on and um
uh it's interesting the guy who who
sort of take f x to be log sub x sub y
huh okay so there he's explaining how
this works
um a hundred years ago
so i think it's pretty interesting
anyway the guy who
supposedly completed this paper a person
called baman added
three paragraphs at the end which i
believe are just riddled with mistakes
which is not a good start for people
understanding this whole thing
um anyway okay
irrelevant um
did he write in english or the
translation
um no no this is a translation
this is this is the translation it was
in german
i was going to say there would have been
you know an interesting irony there
yes yes yes in german and um
and sean frickel wrote in english no i
believe sean finkel did not know english
he i i have his
i have his high school diploma believe
it or not and his college
transcript basically and he learnt
uh russian which was his native language
french german latin and greek but not
english
um okay any case back to back to back to
our agenda
uh how did i get to this oh my gosh i
just pasted it
[Laughter]
okay that's a but the basic conclusion
is he had an out sign but it was
left associative
um okay
you want one more thing here option name
for using discrete
um colors in geo region value plot
um i mean can this thing be a pure color
i mean scaling
right that's the analog of color
function scaling
mean i think color function scaling is
different
in some way a little different but what
does this actually do
this is about the business of binning
we've talked about this like several
times now
see in the first example the colors are
binned into five groups and the second
one it's a continuous scale
right although it seems that colorful
zero none would not really be the way to
express
that right and so we need
can the value of the right hand side be
a pure function
because i'm seeing no examples of that
well
it could be but it would be a function
that would return
bins like what the boundaries are
oh hold on i mean at least for color
function
like right now with geo region value
plot if you set a color function
and then use color data for example it
will
make bins and it will use the color
function you gave it
right right and and so
ignore specifying like rainbow or
something
i mean what we had come up with was
basically
color function goes to list where you
could say what the
you know gradient was and whether to do
it continuous or
into five pieces or use a clustering
algorithm or whatever
sorry i don't understand there's two
different issues there's how you bin
and there's also what actual colors you
use
right and we're looking
for a name for the option for how you
been
right well isn't it color function
binning
yeah and then guests can be
either a number of bins or a list of of
dividers or something like that
or what well but what would its analogy
with the second argument of histogram be
which is also a binning specification
um i mean in other words a number of
bins is a correct thing and the other
thing that histogram has is an absolute
uh that's probably not relevant
well i mean so histogram has the i mean
it has a slightly complicated syntax
because
you can either say go from i mean it
basically allows a range type spec
or you can give a list of a list of
cutoffs
well no no i think for histogram though
the two useful cases
are there which are the the cases that
are most common probably
which are the making five bins or making
bins of size five
right right whereas here
you might want something where you want
things between one and two to be green
things between two and three to be
purple
and so on right right and so that would
be
a rule type syntax
sort of like color rules i mean just it
isn't color rules is it that's not
colored rules because it's got to be
like an interval on the left side
right so you're saying color function
binning
oh by the way you could do such a thing
with piecewise but
maybe it would be better to have a
better syntax than that
yes that that's
horrifying because it involves tests
right piecewise has to have
piecewise has has conditions right
i mean so part of it is i don't think
you want
you want something that you have an easy
handle on what the cutoffs are
because those are what's going to be
used for the labels in the legend
i see whether whether because the labels
are the dividers between different color
levels
correct but why on earth did this unit
end up being so stupid here it needs
we should move it to the top of the
legend instead of
labeling every well but also it needs a
space if it's going to label everything
yeah i'm not sure why it doesn't have a
space
let's look at the cases one other random
question although
it's not showing up here but so maybe
it's actually been fixed but i've
noticed that also the g reagent value
plot often it will
pick weird numbers for the labels which
i assume just based on the bins
that shouldn't happen these days okay
great
i mean so like if you if steven you know
scrolls down and i mean
it's on screen actually that k means
example we're
using you know find clusters with k
means to find seven
colors you know the numbers are all nice
but they aren't evenly spaced
right which brings up a point about
histogram which is right now
histogram has the feature that all the
histograms have to be the same right you
can't just define arbitrary random bins
for a histogram
sure you can how second argument
really okay okay okay okay i'm about to
learn something here
presumably the i mean i am starting to
think that
that the uh color function binning
should have the exact same format as
what is it bin lists and histogram and
so on yes that's what i think as well
right so okay so use wins a bit oh
i see i didn't even know you could do
that
so now the issue is that you have to be
able to then assign
colors to those
and the color function is then taking
these as one two three four five
right
ah there's something from the right is
pointing out in the function repository
that's the function
bin lists by data
i don't know quite how this works how
does this work
um
what did this do i think i have to read
the documentation
you know does this work yet to oh yes it
does
what do you know amazing
right so that's sort of like a group by
operation almost it looks like
in which the values of f of x i lie in
bins
from x-min
oh i see okay so that's a little bit
different that that's
that's um that's an interesting function
but a little different i think
i i agree that i think that the even if
it isn't completely ergonomic i think
that the right thing to do is to just
follow exactly what histogram does
and bin and and and bin lists
right so in other words what we've got
we're getting there
we can have a named thing that's fine
the named ones are going to be the
interesting ones
a lot of the time
what are the what kinds of things are
the named ones um
so the two that you know immediately
come to mind are like
methods available to find clusters
and um like quantile
say quantile comma five or something or
to get
the bottom twenty percent the top twenty
percent and all the twenty percent
well why isn't this this is a log
transformed data why isn't
why isn't if you support scaling
functions
i understand but couldn't you say
quantile here
couldn't you have a version of this
where instead of log you say something
about quantile
was that crazy um
so what happens if you do that with
histogram and
you know i've done examples with this
there may even be one in the docs
is basically all of your bars have the
same height
and they just have different widths
is there anything else that has the same
issues as georgian value plot
i mean i would imagine that we could
extend this
to a lot of the data type fizz functions
but georgian value plots where it comes
up most predominantly is there a
histogram 2d thing that it will also
come up in
um it could be a i mean it could come up
in like density
histogram um
which is the draw a grid of rectangles
sort of thing
where it takes bivariate input and
right right i should use this function
more often
yes the this could have exactly the same
thing color function binning
right i mean it could even be used for
things like array plots
depending on what your data was
that could be neat yeah that would be
neat actually that means because that
would allow you to have something
where continuous data is mapped to
discrete values
so the whole point is that color
function binning would basically
take it so that color function scaling
was false
if color function building was set
there's no scaling and it just is
integer indices
into the color well maybe you can still
do scaling
on or off it just depends on how you
specify your color function
fair enough
um okay so look i think we're basically
agreed here color function binning and
make it work
like um histogram as much as possible
yep okay sounds good okay
so once continuous by default right
what is continuous mean
rather than yes yes so so i'll make
one last push for discrete by default
for georgian value plots which is
so i think you guys you know you like
looking at eastern europe and being able
to see
what the relative ordering of countries
is
rather than having just sort of two
shades of yellow and orange
but it doesn't necessarily help in other
cases
so comparing the
czech republic or poland with portugal
i mean you don't gain any information in
that case
why and i think it's harder you do gain
the info
if it's continuous you're just getting
all the information
well so the other thing that
is you know if you want to know
which countries have the you know per
employee gdp below 50 000 or something
right that's the case where it's more
useful i think is when you actually care
about what the numbers are as with just
the relative
numbers right but but i think that's a
i mean by the way geo region value plot
does it by default
come up with a um scale with a legend
there
it does the legend by default
is there even a way of disabling the
legend can you say plot legendary
false or none or something none will
none will turn it off
okay so legend it plo legends
okay i feel strongly that it should be
should be continuous i think it is much
better to default these visualization
functions to not
you know mess with the data
okay i think that the danger of having
it discrete is that somebody will
conclude
you know in our modern times that you
know
the uh that that you know france and
germany have the exact same or
whatever have they you know have these
they're pretty close at the moment
um uh
um in switzerland
um yeah but i mean that
somebody will say oh their policies
about pandemics were completely
different and yet they got the same
value
but actually that's a i'm
wait a minute a tooltip okay there's a
question about how you can find the
actual value
for germany for example and why isn't it
a tooltip i
don't know why the tooltip's not showing
up because i'm pretty sure it was there
in 12.1 so it's probably just
needs to be added back after i hope this
is rasterized real
oh yeah this is rasterized because i
wanted something that wasn't
yeah that was easily suspendable via
email
um
but i mean but the tool separate of that
the tooltip is missing
right now and it should have it
actually about the matter of file sizes
is it is our geographics bigger or
smaller when you use the new vector
tiles i'm sure they're bigger but i
haven't measured it recently i think it
probably depends on whether your your
thing is mostly ocean i mean exactly it
depends on the region
i was going to say what you want is you
know
remote russia or something what what
would happen here if i said
geo styling what do i say here geo
yeah goes to vector or cluster by the
way don't forget to add those things
into the um
autocomplete yeah where should they show
up in the list
yeah vector go ahead and hit the down
arrow at the bottom of that menu
i don't think that's the complete list
though i don't think
maybe it is well it's not now because it
doesn't have any of the vector stuff
yeah sure um and there i think there may
be one or two that
intentionally didn't include but
certainly not including things like for
example i think there's ways of doing
like dated of country borders but
maybe you shouldn't show that
right that would be nice to have as an
indication that you can do it
right and we don't have street map no
labels in the list
i see it's not a complete list but we do
have to think
jose you should opine what what do we
call it what is it
now what do i say vector vector classic
or vector marketing
that was a fancy dialogue it had there
and why did it come back as
a different thing before it came back as
this that was a classic
right it came back to classic before it
came to
that's very beautiful and look at look
at that resolution
that's lovely look at norway
so by the way i mean does it uh is there
are there ways of uh
getting the polygons out outside of
these uh
functions oh i see that's the classic
if you set the zoom level with the board
what happened to the
what happened here why is that why is
there a
because the polygons have lower
resolution you can
you can increase the zoom so there is
still some freedom here
and so to get smaller sizes because
with vectors we have the risk of having
large sizes the zoom is
a bit probably smaller but
but we can't disagree between
the zoom level don't do you understand
the point is if you set geo zoom level
to
something higher then it will lie right
but how can it not line up i don't
understand how it doesn't line up
level is one if you're zoomed out to
show the whole earth you don't want to
show all the fjords
so so so the polygons are coming from
two different sources so
the the ones that the original value
plot is using
are the entity value polygons that do
not depend on zoom they are fixed they
are quite high some
and then the ones that we are using for
the background they do depend on zoom
because they are tiled etc
so maybe actually because my my
understanding is that
polygon of an entity is actually
slightly different than entity of quotes
polygon
right and so maybe you would make sense
no they are the same well but the
polygon eventually doesn't immediately
evaluate density of polygon is that
right
that's right but when need evaluates it
unloads exactly
right okay but so it could be the case
that polygon of entity
is treated so that we use a polygon for
the correct zoom level
like so that so it'll actually perfectly
line up i don't know if we
have the polygons of you know all the
countries and all the
cities and stuff like that at all these
zoom levels or
could be computed but that might be nice
it we we will be able to do that in the
future but at the moment we just have
tiles and we cannot separate say the
countries or the provinces or whatever
right
just have the tiles with everything
inside so
your level goes to i don't know three or
four probably to get a much better
result okay right
it might be possible to compute the top
leg for us to actually build the tiles
given the polygons that we have
but that's maybe a different this may be
a different issue
this is yes i i agree but but this is
really not very good what happened here
i mean this is something we need to fix
before vector becomes default
try setting the the zoom level to be
much higher and see if it's what is that
that's splendid that's what kaliningrad
it's part of russia
oh yeah right
the um
okay so wait a minute you're saying set
um geo zoom level
to i don't know why three or four i
would say
it's going to take longer to unload the
data
but the result will be better you know i
would argue that should say downloading
geo
tiles processing vector geo data
oh wow right so the the new sub-levels
have more information including
sub-regions and okay but something else
went wrong look
greece got because it's in the
background right
because the labels is this set the geo
background right not
geo i mean maybe this is something that
could happen with the labels get put on
top of your
data but so the the the polygons that
your region value plot is plotting
are on top of the background i
understand i understand but but
since the background is now vector and
now has its labels separated from
everything else
in principle those labels could be
sandwiched on top of
the um uh on top of the geo region value
plot
polygons could be we don't have the
mechanism for that yet
but that's another thing you're going to
have to deal with because this is really
stupid
what happens there
well i think that's partly also an
artifact the fact that you did way too
high
zoom level for the map right because
normally it wouldn't show that label
it's only showing that label because
well normally it would show that the
craziness
of these of these mismatches wherever it
was well but
even at the higher zoom level but it was
still sort of mismatched
yeah yeah like a look at northern norway
and the high resolution one if you
scroll down again
why the heck did that happen
is that because our central polygon
doesn't include certain islands
what about the what is that is that what
the heck is that what's that feral
islands
i'm looking more at the things the
little little weird stuff at the
very top of norway no i understand i
mean who knows maybe maybe these are
like you know
underwater for half the year or
something like that it's kind of unclear
i have no idea but
um we're adjusting for climate change in
some places and not
in other words are either glaciers
maybe they're ice i don't know i mean
who knows so perhaps we went too too far
in
in some level so we now have
the background has more even more ideas
what's that
um so the the
the polygon for germany in that case
will not have necessarily all the
islands
yeah i think that's an i think that's a
island it looks like i'm looking at
google maps
right exactly that's an island that is
is in the background
data but not in there not in the polygon
for germany
in entity value correct is that because
it's not using the geo-variant
all areas or something like that right
because if it used all areas it would
have you know
uh you know for for the uk it would have
all kinds of random little islands in
the indian ocean
right right so these are all decisions
which are balanced in the sense of
showing important things but not
having too much well i think what's
clear is that the geo region value plot
there is a useful geo variant which is
show all the geographically nearby stuff
because that's what's going to be
relevant for geo region value plot you
don't need the
actually it seems like what you really
want to do is you want to show
all of them but then you want to set the
plot range based on only a few of them
well that's right
that's right you don't want the rock in
the indian ocean i think eventually what
we need to do
is to synchronize the zooms and if we
don't load polygons for some
region with samsung then everything else
dealing with that region should use the
same zoom
right but that requires christopher's
idea of the symbolic polygon of entity
well but we already have that is
so it is that in entity value we don't
have a possibility of downloading a zoom
for a polygon with a zoom right
it would need to be injected somehow
right right that would be very nice
for other reasons that would be very
useful to have right
well we should do that i mean so that
that means that it in the entity value
stuff that becomes an attribute
right we should do that we haven't
thought of that before
and another point is maybe we could have
uh right i mean for stuff like countries
obviously we'd want to to download them
at different zoom levels and
buy those but for other stuff where we
only have you know
high-resolution polygons for example if
you know your
city boundaries or something like that
where maybe you don't have many zoom
levels
we might want to also have something
which computes the zoom level so you can
still access that
what do you mean compute it says what
the zoom valve is
polygons with different zoom levels i
don't know if that's an easy computation
actually
maybe it isn't in which case it no but i
think that the
it is worthwhile for the attribute just
like you can say what date
was that population figure from you can
get an attribute that says what zoom
level is this default from
right and the region so the two things
that we have discussed with francisco is
to be able to specify
the zoom and the region because
sometimes you want a very very high sum
but only for a small region because you
don't want to download
zoom 14 of all the us that would be too
much data if you are interested on the
in in the region around new york
right but listen listen the other thing
you're highlighting i think it's correct
that geo region value plot
should essentially as if produce
all the off-screen indian idol and you
know indian ocean islands
but then set at zoom level set its plot
range
somehow your range technically
yeah geo range right i guess there's a
do we have a geo
we don't currently have for geo region
value plots geo
range arrow automatic is not yet a thing
well this is just this isn't even
georgia i plug specific this is just a
geographic
thing right wow i mean i guess the
this is again would rely on this
distinction between polygon of entity
and entity of quotes polygon right
because the point is that if you have
entity of quotes polygon
it's just a bunch of lines it knows
nothing about it doesn't know that
alaska isn't important or something like
that
um and so it'll have to show it but if
you write polygon of of
entity you know us then you could
imagine that it would render alaska but
it would know something about what the
relevant plot default plot range should
be
and not show it if that makes sense
right right because because in other
words you have to feed in
the geovariant information has to know
even though alaska is big we don't want
to include it in making a generic
picture of the
winner you do want to include it like
okay so i
i'm trying to think of what the right
concept of this is i mean it's a level
it's like some sort of
i don't think we're going to solve the
alaska problem today
no but i mean the point the point here i
mean what we're talking about here
is this concept of by the way bob on
live streamers has realized the point
that for example
uh hawaii is an issue right and so this
is why we have this notion
of all areas center default map area
principal area and simplified area right
the point is no matter what you set
there
it'll you know once you've set it it'll
show all of them if that makes sense
like the geo range will be
set to kind of show as many as possible
but the point is is that
you could imagine another way of doing
it because the point is this does
lead to some issues for example where
you know you use geo region value plot
or something like that and
and alaska is just blank and that looks
bizarre
obviously you know and so one
you know this the alternative ideas may
be that somehow
you sort of have associated with you
know the us
or something like that here's the
default geo range
that you want to that you want to use
even though the polygon that you're
actually rendering is bigger than it
exactly that that's exactly what what we
are planning to do with francisco just
that it hasn't been implemented in
involved from alpha so it is the
distinction of geovariant
sorry of geo range and the what we call
the map geo range
uh which is the recommended
range to show that particular polygon i
get it
yeah that makes sense is that is that
like something that's that's stored in
the actual polygon object
exactly it's a property of the entity us
for example and then the plan is to have
the u.s to come
back always with alaska but geographics
will call not the
geo range but the map geo range okay
beautiful
that's that's wonderful okay yeah
exactly exactly and then
alaska will be there but not shown so
that if you enlarge the area
then it will be there okay cool great
so actually the geographic part is
already implemented
the the world from alphabet is the part
that needs implementation
right i'm noticing sanders comment if
the netherlands had a central lake i'm
not sure why he says that
is there something other than just that
it would be interesting
for the for um we can now handle it
without polygons with holes we can now
handle that just fine
and san marino and all those kinds of
things um
although although this is maybe a
off-topic note but
in most of the entities in most of the
places with entities they use filled
curve instead of polygon
that's being fixed right because we
didn't have polygons with holes until
version two right
yeah i know yeah so is that being fixed
so we knew we were going to have
geopolygon eventually so
and now we have it in 12 2. so now the
idea is to change directly
not to polygon of geopositions with
holes but to geopolygons directly
which also handles the annotation with
with actually this is also off topic but
are there
sort of because this has been like an
everlasting frustration with doing some
geo stuff is that
often you want to convert it to a mesh
region to do fancier processing
is it now possible to like reliably
convert between geopolygons and
mesh regions or boundary mesh regions or
something
so because the conversion depends on the
projection you are using so what we have
done is to have
the polygons of geogrid position to be
convertible
to to mesh regions okay beautiful yeah
yeah that's
great is that documented properly jose
because that will be super confusing
with people if they if they say
region discrete ties region or something
and then
yeah it should generate the right
messages i think what discretized region
does is it does it in 3d now
which i think is also probably the right
thing to do although it's a little bit
funky
um right so that's a discussion we had
with charles so
he he wanted to because we have the flat
computations and the
curved earth computation he wanted to go
directly to 3d
for the cases in which we have a
non-projected
case now i i honestly would like to have
a way of going back
to a projection from the mesh region but
we don't yet have
that i mean project a mesh region a 3d
mesh region onto 2d
exactly because once you have the 3d you
are you are stuck in 3d
you cannot go back to 2d well couldn't
you with
x y z couldn't you kind of do that i
mean
you end up with this triangulated thing
which i guess isn't quite what you want
i mean geo position xyz is still a 3d
thing
yeah but right but you can convert from
geo position xyz to
regular geoposition in a projection yes
but
you would have to extract first from the
mesh so the idea would be to do that
with the mesh
to get a 2d mesh so it would be nice to
have a way of going
from the 3d mesh to the 2d mesh we have
you having to extract manually the
positions
do the computation and then re
introducing another mesh
yeah yeah well i think that's
maybe that's such as life because at
some level the mesh region doesn't
know that it's you know that that it
that it's
the the earth or something like that or
whatever it is
it doesn't know that it's the that its
region is the surface of a sphere or
something close to a sphere so it can't
uh
possibly do that well ideally the mesh
region would store
the geo position itself and then it
would be very easy to
or your position xyz okay
that would be interesting yeah you know
but
sorry go ahead
yeah bob was just commenting maybe it'd
be nice to be able to customize which
islands are included which not i mean
we did this a long long long time ago we
we picked
for wolfman alpha we picked which things
were these various principle things and
i don't think we've really revisited
that
and i don't think there is a good way of
parametrizing i mean it is a real can of
worms
like we're talking islands that don't
even have names we're talking all kinds
of weird stuff
we're talking about little name you kind
of know whether or not to include it in
the principal area
sure but in when you know if you end up
with one of these mismatches where some
random little piece of land off some
fjord somewhere
is you know like what is that what's
that
there for example you know or that part
of norway actually it's a named
um
yeah okay what about when a piece of
antarctica breaks off
you know on the edge of antarctica it
breaks off and now it's an island
and it's you know part of glacier number
such and such
it's i mean it's going to get very weird
but but i agree that there's a
you know like like if you were to say
for the uk where i happen to know the
geography more or less
you know do you include the channel
islands do you include the isle of man
you know those are at least named you
use the shetland and orkney islands
um these i don't actually know what the
name of those is
gosh i don't know what the names of
these things off the coast of scotland
are but like for example i can imagine
say
include the the you know the shetland
islands but not the orkney islands
or include the channel islands but not
the isle of man or whatever
um i i think the right thing is just to
trust the zoom levels
and and just choose the sub level that
you want because right now with the
polygons in entity value we only have a
decision that was made some years ago
i see all right well that's a good start
at least
right there's one more comment on a live
stream from jonas about
um let's see using
dots and so on instead of colors that is
a
i mean that's this question about icon
plot and so on where we have where you
can put little
images of people in these countries to
indicate numbers of numbers of things i
don't know what the status of that is
i think we were going to try and
experiment that with that in the
function repository
i mean the problem is what do you do
with liechtenstein you know you've got
let's say you're saying
you know gdp per capita or whatever this
is and the number is really high in san
marino but it's a really really small
place what do you do
you need to have a call out but that's
really hard
right although right although we're
getting more sophisticated
you know as we you know in this version
with our vector graphics and vector
labeling and so on
um you know we're getting a lot more
sophisticated about about avoid you know
labels
putting labels in reasonable places and
so on
all right well i think that's probably
enough for
for um two and a half hours later
yes well we got through the agenda at
least um
and uh good stuff all right well thanks
guys and
thanks to folks on the live stream